as a result of a swirling disk of gas
and dust
that stuck together and formed the earth
in a rotating solar system
the earth ceaselessly rotates around its
axis revealing a nearby star to wherever
you are
within every 24-hour period at some
point
in coordination with this today you wake
up
your consciousness and ordinary function
turn back on after having been shut down
for around five to eight hours
fundamentally you don't know why you did
this why you shut yourself off for some
prolonged period of mostly unconscious
vulnerability
no one fully does you do however do it
for about one third of every day
which equals to about three to four
months of every year
while you were asleep you dreamt around
four to six different times you probably
don't remember
maybe one or two of them if any they
were likely very strange
and the recalling of them is probably
even stranger you don't know why you
dreamt
and you don't know why your brain
created those particular arrangements of
experiences
and memories and imagine concepts of
impossibilities
blended together into a specific
self-induced mental simulation
of reality of course no one fully knows
in between each dream in terms of your
conscious sense of awareness
your you there was nothing a deathly
oblivion that you dipped in and out of
with each oscillating type of brainwave
after this mini fantasy-infused death
dream roller coaster
you get up and likely stand under a
spout that pours an essentially endless
stream of liquid
onto you the liquid is almost the same
as the gas you just slept in
except there are two additional atoms of
another gas added to it
forming a new molecular arrangement
during this
you rub some manufactured slimy goop on
the outer layer of your body
so it doesn't smell bad because you
might smell after having laid down and
done nothing for several hours
after cleaning and covering yourself you
might put some stuff in the large
opening of your face
you almost certainly eat some form of
dead plants or animals
because you must in some form or another
in order to keep your own life
alive you'll have to do this again
numerous times throughout the day
you might not remember to however until
your body starts creating a clenching
sensation
and making your brain feel light-headed
or angry or uncomfortable
because sometimes oftentimes your body
has to inflict discomfort or pain onto
you
in order to remind you when or when not
to do things
after this you probably hopefully brush
the sharp
hard objects sticking out of the opening
in your face with some paste
so to ensure that they don't smell and
deteriorate generally speaking
you have now done all the necessary
preparatory stuff in order to start your
day
and exist in the world of other people
all of who basically just did
the same sorts of things depending on
the order of the days in which the earth
has rotated around its axis in relation
to the sun
within a seven day cycle you will likely
interact with other people throughout
the day
perhaps in an effort towards some
mutually agreed upon goal of work
perhaps more casually with people who
you were born in biological association
with
or perhaps with people who you have met
and liked enough to keep around
whoever they are in order to interact
and communicate they will all attempt to
translate electrical firings in their
brain
turn sensations turn thoughts turned
words moving the base of their skull
up and down in order to register and
reverberate them into electrical firings
in your own
and vice versa you will likely
understandably
have a fairly hard time during some of
these interactions
throughout the day you also probably see
strangers as you pass by
walking or driving you might meet
glances with a few
some of whom you might exchange a small
nod or grin in a recognition of the
moment
perhaps not each one of these people
will be moving through their own
entirely unique
complex day and life experiencing this
passing fleeting moment with just as
much central feeling
and point of view as you and yet you
will likely see them as they see you
with some level of overarching personal
indifference and objectification
despite this you will sense that you are
an entity in their mind
and you will likely act or feel slightly
different in their momentary gaze
mostly all of these people you will
never see again
nor will they see you their string of
moments will continue on in another
direction
that you will never know but will be
just as intense and meaningful to them
as yours to you
you will live and move across the planet
throughout the day while the planet
itself moves and lives through some
unending space of apparent nothingness
that you nor anyone else throughout the
entirety of the planet's history
has ever had any real accurate clue as
to what it truly is
and where it leads in every moment the
earth will move to a different position
in space
never to return to the exact same one
ever again
you will breathe your eyelids will blink
your heart will beat
your blood will pump the entirety of the
complex vessel that you call your body
will operate all day almost entirely on
its own
mostly all of which needs to operate
properly for any of the rest too
and if the rest doesn't you don't you
might have strange thoughts throughout
the day
some of which you might find
disconcerting some that might not even
really feel like you
certain experiences and perceptions
might trigger desires or repulsions or
thoughts
that are perhaps counter to what you
might hold to be acceptable
or in line with who you think you are
and should be you might wonder why you
have thoughts that you don't want to
have
and if supposedly you don't what part of
you is thinking them
you might feel disgusted or upset with
yourself your inabilities or your social
interactions
as they unfold messily onto the world or
at least messily inside your head
as if you are clumsily navigating a
large piece of machinery that you can't
access all the controls to
you will go through this day and many
more just like it many with even weirder
or more troubling experiences
unmentioned
you will feel and experience the
strangeness of your own show exclusively
backstage behind the curtained off self
that is you
at the end of the day again depending on
the day of the week
you might feel like doing nothing
however doing nothing won't quite be
enough
so as a compromise you might watch
colored pixels dance around in the form
of different still images on a screen
presenting visuals of people you don't
know but have perhaps become drawn to
with a sincere sense of connection
to the artificial story they tell or
person they play
soon you go to your designated spot in
order to turn off and recharge again
perhaps you might fall asleep right away
or perhaps
at least this night you might find a
challenge in turning yourself off so
easily
perhaps the strangeness of everything
that just happened and is still
happening
everything that you're supposed to
otherwise suppose as normal
was and is frankly from this view
pretty strange and perhaps as you notice
this strangeness
you might feel as though you personally
are strange in a way that must be more
exclusive to you
because essentially everyone else you
saw today and every other day
basically seemed fine and like
everything was totally normal
but to them so did you in truth
even the most basic of acts done by even
the most so-called normal and stable of
people
are from a zoomed in lens completely
strange and weird
oftentimes in most contexts our oddness
is deemed quite normal
which is fine and well but it does
however make our so-called normalcy
quite odd when you think about it in
these late night hours or moments of
reflection
however arguably these odd moments of
reflection of an odd day and odd life
a sense of personal strangeness or
isolation or craziness
is perhaps the most undoubtedly normal
thing
any of us could experience to you to me
to everyone
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video or enjoy pursuit of
wonder content in general
you might enjoy the new pursuit of
wonder affiliated book
notes from the end of everything which
you can find through the link in the
description
you